This lecture is about mixture model
estimation.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing probabilistic topic
models.
In particular, we're going to talk
about how to estimate the parameters of
a mixture model.
So let's first look at our motivation
for using a mixture model and we hope
to factor out the background words from
the topic word distribution.
So the idea is to assume that the text
data actually contain two kinds of
words.
One kind is from the background here.
So the is away etc and the other kind
is from our topic word distribution
that we're interested in.
So in order to solve this problem of
factoring out background words, we can
set up our mixture model as follows.
We're going to assume that we already
know the parameters of all the
values for all the parameters in the
mixture model except for the word
distribution of theta sub D, which
is our target. So this is the case of customizing a probalistic model so that we embed the unknown variables that we are interested in. But we are going to simplify other things. We are going to assume we have knowledge about others.
And this is a powerful way of
customizing a model for a particular
need.
Now you can imagine we could have
assumed that we also don't know the
background word distribution, but in this case our
goal is factor out precisely those
high probability background words.
So we assume the background model is
already fixed.
And the problem here is how can we
adjust theta sub D in order to
maximize the probability of the
observed document here and we assume
all the other parameters are known.
Now, although we designed the model
heuristically to try to factor out this
background words.
It's unclear whether if we use maximum
likelihood estimator we will actually
end up having order distribution where
the common words like the will be
indeed having smaller probabilities
than before.
So now.
In this case, it turns out that the
answer is yes, and
when we set up the probalistic model in
this way when we use maximum likelihood
estimator we will end up having a word
distribution that where the common
words will be factored out via the use
of the background distribution.
So to understand why this is so, it's
useful to examine the behavior of a
mixture model.
So we're going to look at a very, very
simple case in order to understand some
interesting behaviors of a mixture
model the observed patterns here
actually are generalizable to mixture
model in general, but it's much easier
to understand this behavior when we use
a very simple case like what we're
seeing here.
So specifically in this case.
Let's assume that the probability of
choosing each of the two models is
exactly the same, so we're going to
flip fair coin to decide which model to
use.
Furthermore, we are going to assume
there are precisely two words: the and
text.
Obviously this is a very naive
oversimplification of the actual text,
but again it is useful to examine
the behavior in such a special
case.
So we further assume that the
background model gives probability of
point nine to the word
the and text point one.
Now, let's also assume that our data is
extremely simple.
The document has just the two words
text and the.
So now let's write down the likelihood
function in such a case. First,
what's the probability of text and
what's the probability of the?
I hope by this point and you will be
able to write it down.
So the probability of text is basically
the sum over 2 cases, where each case
corresponds to each of the word
distribution.
And it accounts for the two ways of
generating text.
An inside each case we have the
probability of choosing the model which
is .5 multiplied by the probability of
observing text from that model.
Similarly, the would have a probability
of the same form, just with different
exact probabilities.
So naturally our likelihood function is
just the product of the two, so it's
very easy to see that.
Once you understand what's the
probability of each word, which is also
why it's so important to understand
what exactly the probability of
observing each word from such a
mixture model.
Now the interesting question now is,
how can we then optimize this
likelihood?
Well, you will notice that there were
only two variables.
They are precisely the two
probabilities of the two words text and
the given by theta sub D.
And this is because
we have assumed all the other
parameters are known.
So now the question is a very simple
algebra question, right?
So we have a simple expression with two
variables and we hope to choose the
values of these two variables to maximize
this function.
And the exercise that we have seen some
simple algebra problems and note that
the two probabilities must sum to one.
So there's some constraint.
If there were no constraint, of course
we would set both probabilities to
their maximum value, which would be one
to maximize this.
But we can't do that because text and
the must sum to one.
We can't give both a probability of 1.
So now the question is how should we
allocate the probability mass between
the two words?
What do you think?
Now it would be useful to look at this
formula for moment and to see what
intuitively what we do in order to set these
probabilities to maximize the value of
this function.
OK, if we look into this further then
we'll see some interesting behavior of
the two component models in that they
will be collaborating to maximize the
probability of the observed data which
is dictated by the maximum likelihood
estimator.
But there are also competing in someway
an in particular they will be
competing on the words.
And they will tend to bet high
probabilities on different words to
avoid this competition in some sense.
Or to gain advantage in this
competition.
So again, looking at this objective
function and we have a constraint.
On the two probabilities.
Now.
If you look at the formula intuitively,
you might feel that you want to set the
probability of text to be somewhat
larger than the.
And this intuition can be well
supported by a mathematical fact, which
is when the sum of two variables is a
constant.
Then the product of them, which is
maximum when they are equal and this is
a fact that we know from algebra.
Now if we plug that in, it will
mean that we have to make the two
probabilities equal.
And when we make them equal an, if we
consider the constraint that we can
easy to solve this problem and the
solution is the probability of text
would be point nine and probability
of the is point one.
And as you can see, indeed the
probability of text is now much larger
than probability of the.
This is not the case when we have just
one distribution and this is clearly
because of the use of the background
model which assigns a very high
probability to the and low probability to
text.
And if you look at the equation, you
will see obviously some interaction of
the two distributions here.
In particular, you will see in order to
make them equal and then the
probability assigned by theta sub D
must be higher for a word that has a
smaller probability given by the
background.
And, this is obvious from examining
this equation because the background
part is weak for text it's small.
So in order to compensate for that we
must make the probability of text given
by theta sub D somewhat larger so that
the two sides can be balanced.
So this is in fact a very general
behavior of this mixture model, and
that is if one distribution assigns a
high probability to one word than
another, then the other distribution.
Would tend to do the opposite.
Basically it would discourage
other distributions to do the same,
and this is to balance them out so that
we can account for all kinds of words.
And this also means that by using a
background model that is fixed to
assign high probabilities to background
words, we can indeed encourage the
unknown topic world distribution to
assign smaller probabilities for such
common words, instead put more
probability mass on the content words
that cannot be explained well by the
background model.
Meaning that they have a very small
probability from the background model,
like a text here.